welcome to the lovely Oh rescue it's a
second year that we've done this what do
you love about this cause well anything
with animals dogs in general I'm like a
big stickler for I think it's really
important for people to rescue puppies
and its really amazing that this
organization like helps you with the
medical needs for the dogs if you can't
pay 3000 $4000 it's very expensive so it
just means a lot that they really care
about the animals and they do everything
they can and help them find a really
good home dogs do you have now I have
one dog but I've had I've had a bunch of
dogs are you in the market for a new in
tonight is that happening understand
like I'm baking my mom I'm like please I
just want to take every dog that I can
I'm obsessed
I've already seen one that I'm like I
want you so it's hard it's gonna be hard
tomorrow on your Instagram we might see
you with a new puppets possible I think
it's very possible I don't know if my
mom knows that but it's gonna happen
yeah yeah we apologize she literally
like she all she talked about was how
obsessed she is and she wants every dog
she can so maybe you know is she here
with you tonight she is we're gonna make
this happen I'm gonna help you put in a
good word you have a really busy year
ahead you joined West Side Story which
is so huge how was it to shoot that
you're part of the Jets right yes I'm
one of the jet girls it was honestly one
of the best experiences I've ever had
like to work with Steven Spielberg was a
pretty life-changing thing so I'm just
really grateful for that what do you
think is the biggest difference between
the new version and the original well
we've stayed really true to the value of
the first movie and we really wanted to
bring that back to life we didn't want
to make it too modern it's very still in
the 1960s which is so incredible so the
costumes the hair and the makeup is all
very from that era which is amazing I
think we just added more Flair from this
new cast and that everyone was so
incredible so I'm excited I cannot wait
how's the dancing in it I feel like you
I mean they only got the best dancers
and I'm was so lucky to just be a part
of such I wasn't you know just to be a
little part in that movie was I can
credible and I learned so much from all
the dancers and actors and everyone is
brilliant I'll have another movie coming
out but I feel like we've been waiting
for Kate Hudson and SIA directed it how
is it to really tap into that type of
role you play an autistic character
right and how was that for you what did
you learn
yeah I mean I learned a lot about myself
in that process I learned a lot about
people on the spectrum and how beautiful
that world is and I really I took a
while to tap into just because I wanted
to get it right but I also wanted to
really pay just a really nice tribute to
everybody and yeah so it was really fun
but it's also such a weird and like
crazy movie and I'm it's been I found it
when I was 14 and I'm 17 so I've been
waiting four years for this when is it
coming out again is it I don't know
exactly but I yeah I hope soon yeah
waiting since I think you guys are now
used to do where is this movie it's like
the most epic path ever we're just
really we want to get it right so I
rather take as long as it needs to to
get it perfectly right so yeah you are
one of the best dancers in the world
ever would you ever consider judging a
dancing competition show like world of
dance I mean you've been on Dancing with
the Stars would that ever be of interest
to I did actually judge the kid version
of So You Think so that would be fun to
do it again I feel like now that I've
grown up a little bit more and have more
experience I feel like I could tap into
that again but it's hard because I never
want to like I just want to enjoy and
never like criticize anyone so I'm
always gonna if I do judge again I'll
just be like the happy judge that
encourages everyone cuz we need more of
I know there's some times the judges are
a little harsh and I just want to be
like the happy nice 1:17 I feel like you
are so busy how are you balancing the
personal life the work of it all yeah I
mean I mean this morning I was doing
school like we're still doing school
every morning this is my last year so
I'm really just trying to like get it
over with and it's been great I mean
somehow like being so busy I've somehow
managed to fit in school
friends family and we just make it work
because I really take what's personal
and like important in my life and I just
make it work I feel like you've always
been very like quiet about your personal
life
though why is that like is there a
reason behind that um I think there's so
much that's on social media nowadays and
I feel like so much is already out there
and the open that there has to be some
that I want just for myself and I think
that's I'm learning that I was I'm
getting older I'm learning oh it's okay
to keep things more private I think it's
more enjoyable that way and yeah it's
more precious that way so I'm just
taking every little bit that I can and
just keeping it to myself and my friends
and family and it's great pay attention
to all the rumors and all the
speculation up I try to ignore it
because I mean people think I'm dating
everyone like I'm just sick I'm just you
know just tried Disneyland but not a
friend I know right we're not every boy
I'm with has to be a boyfriend so yeah
but thanks for setting that straight for
us yeah
[Music]